you've been pretty vocal about your
experience with the Disney Channel Miley
it wasn't always your cup of tea but you
drink it anyway
and we're happy you did because it
turned you into the big star you are
today so you're not the only celebrity
who used Hannah Montana as a
stepping-stone tons of young actors
guest-starred on the show only to move
on to bigger and better things I used to
like carrots but then you said you hated
them so then I hated them believe it or
not but some of the actors from Hannah
Montana would go on to star on TV shows
like vampire diaries community and
Pretty Little Liars
keep watching to find out which
descendants stars got her big break on
the Disney sitcom Alison Brie Alison
Brie is a 36 year old actress who has
one of the most impressive portfolios of
all time many of us know her as Annie
Edison from the hilarious TV series
community and others recognize her as
Trudy Campbell from Mad Men but before
Allison made a name for herself in the
industry she appeared in a single
episode of Hannah Montana that's right
in 2006 when Allison was just 24 years
old she portrayed Nina in the episode
titled
it's my party and I'll lie if I want to
rico paid nina to pretend to have a
crush on him which must with jackson's
head but in reality Nina had feelings
for Jackson which messed things up even
more by the end of the episode both neko
and Jackson would be bald
turns out chopping each other's hair off
was the only way to solve their girl
problems just one year after appearing
on the Disney sitcom Allison would land
a permanent role on Mad Men turning her
into an instant star
Taman sir sock before taman sir sock was
celebrated for portraying Jenna Marshall
on Pretty Little Liars she appeared in a
total of nine episodes of Hannah Montana
in 2010 Taman would play the role of
Sienna a rich bikini model who fell in
love with Jackson despite all of their
differences Jackson and Sienna met at
the beginning of season four and
everyone was shocked when Sienna
revealed that she had feelings for
Jackson Salmons popularity might have
blown up when she joined the cast of
Pretty Little Liars but she was a big
deal long before she stole the show as
Jenna
Taman is currently 36 years old but back
when she was 17 she made her grand
on the set of the Australian TV show
home in a way Taman would portray Danny
Sutherland for a total of four years
before starring on The Young and the
Restless from 2007 to 2009 it's hard to
believe that Jackson's on-screen
girlfriend was such a huge celebrity in
real life Kat Graham if you're a fan of
the Vampire Diaries you probably know a
thing or two about Kat Graham but did
you know that she guest-starred on three
episodes of Hannah Montana from 2008 to
2009 Kat was known for playing Jackson's
a plus girlfriend Alison
Rico did everything he could to ruin
Jackson's date with Allison and while he
wasn't exactly successful their
relationship quickly fizzled out Kat is
well known for portraying Bonnie Bennett
for a total of eight seasons but before
she joined the cast of The Vampire
Diaries Kat appeared in a handful of
sitcoms as a one-time character Kat
first stepped on the scene in 1998 when
she was cast as Jackie in The Parent
Trap and she would go on to land small
roles in TV shows like lizzie mcguire
malcolm in the middle' in the OSI on top
of being a wonderful actress kat is also
a dancer she's a well known backup
dancer who has appeared in plenty of
music videos like Justin Bieber's
somebody to love do you remember when
Kat portrayed Allison on Hannah Montana
tell us in the comments Stirling night
if you love watching Disney Channel
you're probably well aware that Stirling
night played Demi Lovato's on-screen
lover on sunny with a chance Stirling
portrayed Chad Dylan Cooper on the show
and would go on to reprise his role on
the TV series so random but before
Stirling became a big deal in the
industry he had a one-time role on
Hannah Montana in 2007 Stirling was cast
as Lucas in the episode titled my best
friend's boyfriend
he played Lily's first real boyfriend
but Lucas quickly got on Miley's nerves
when she started feeling like a third
wheel by the end of the episode Miley
would catch Lucas cheating but Lily
wouldn't believe her claiming Miley was
just jealous she had to see it for
herself and boy did she ever two years
after appearing on Hannah Montana
with kasnas alex in the hit film 17
again which would serve as his
breakthrough role sterling is currently
filming the upcoming TV series Katey
keen he's all set to star as Randy Van
ronk Fenton Austin Butler just like
sterling Austin Butler appeared in a
single episode of Hannah Montana and
coincidentally both of these stars had
pivotal roles in the episode titled my
best friend's boyfriend Austin played
Sterling's on-screen cousin Derek Lily's
set him up with Miley so that she
wouldn't feel like a third wheel anymore
but Miley and Derek just didn't hit it
off Miley went as far as to call their
date the worst date of her life after
appearing on Hannah Montana in 2007
Austin was cast as zippy Brewster in
Ned's Declassified School Survival Guide
since then Austin's acting career has
really taken off he's starred on TV
shows like arrow switched at birth and
the shannara chronicles' Austin even
managed to get cast as Tex Watson in
Quentin Tarantino's film Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood and believe it or not
but Austin is all set to play the king
of rock himself in the upcoming untitled
Elvis Presley project which will hit the
big screen sometime in 2021 keep
watching to find out which two actors
start on Hannah Montana before landing
lead roles on Disney Channel's ant farm
if you love hearing about old Disney
shows like Hannah Montana you're going
to love the things we boast daily videos
about your favorite Disney stars movies
and sitcoms so hit that big red
subscribe button and
don't forget to personalise your
notifications so you never miss another
video if you're watching on your mobile
go on your YouTube settings and enable
notifications
Jehan alias Genevieve camellias orgy as
she likes to be called has come a long
way since playing Tiffany in the Hannah
Montana episode titled Jake another
little piece of my heart
this was G's first ever role but
certainly not her last G was only 11
years old when she appeared on Hannah
Montana and she was missing her front
teeth which was both hilarious and
adorable she would go on to play Dakota
condor on Sonny with a Chance and Joe
keener on good luck charlie but the role
she is most famous for is the one of
Avery Jennings on dog with a blog since
leaving Disney Channel gia has continued
to pursue a career in acting and in 2017
she was cast as crista Carlyle in
American vandal obviously G was born for
the limelight she's got a super
impressive portfolio for a 20 year old
and she's just getting started for event
blue corbin blue is one of the most
well-known disney stars of all time
everyone remembers him as Chad Danforth
Troy Bolton's best friend
Corbin starred in all three High School
Musical movies he's a triple threat who
is highly committed to the arts back in
2006
Corbin was cast as Johnny Colleen on the
hit sitcom Hannah Montana he would go on
to appear in two episodes from 2006 to
2008 Corbin played Miley's on-screen
crush and in the episode titled were all
on this date together Johnny and Rico
get into a bidding war in hopes of
winning a date with Hannah Montana
we loved Miley and Corben's chemistry
and we especially loved their song if we
were a movie it was a total hit Selena
Gomez is there anyone in the world who
hasn't heard of Selena Gomez we highly
doubt it because while the stars large
Instagram following speaks for itself
but before she became one of the most
celebrated pop stars in the world Selena
got her star on the Disney Channel from
2007 to 2012
Selena played Alex Russo on Wizards of
Waverly Place after leaving the Disney
Channel Selena pursued a music career
and quickly
topped the charts as one of the best
female artists she's accomplished so
much that it's easy to forget where her
journey all began do you remember when
Selena portrayed Mikaela on a Hannah
Montana she appeared in a total of three
episodes which aired from 2007 to 2008
Hannah and Mikayla were on-screen rivals
they constantly competed for a spot in
the limelight they were total frenemies
Sierra McCormick Sierra McCormick is
only 22 years old but she's already got
a huge online following she first made
waves when she was cast as Emma on the
hilarious
TV series Curb Your Enthusiasm but in
2009 Sierra would appear in a single
episode of Hannah Montana alongside one
of her future ant farm co-stars Sierra
appeared in the episode titled welcome
to the bungle she portrayed a young girl
named Jillian who was one of Hannah's
biggest fans during a Q&A interview
Jillian asked Hannah whether or not she
liked to read and totally broke down in
front of everyone while she didn't have
the biggest role on the sitcom Sierra
would go on to star as olive Doyle on
ant farm from 2011 to 2014 if you want
to see more of Sierra keep an eye out
for the upcoming film exploited Sierra
has been cast as Chloe one of the lead
characters exploited is all set to make
its grand debut sometime in 2020 Chyna
and MacLean and last but not least is
the beautiful and talented China and
McClain who is currently playing
Jennifer Pierce aka lightning on the hit
TV series Black Lightning china anne
mcclain is a child actor who has made
quite the name for herself in Hollywood
she landed her first acting gig in 2005
and has continued to add to her
portfolio ever since China has made it
big as a Disney Channel star she's well
known for playing uma and The
Descendants series and just like Sierra
McCormick Chyna got her start on Hannah
Montana before starring as Chyna parks
on ant farm
Chyna and Sierra both appeared in the
episode titled welcome to the bungle
Chyna was cast as Isabel an extremely
devoted fan of Hannah Montana's Chyna is
a triple threat in real life she
demonstrated her mini talents in
descendants 2 & 3 and
if the franchise can't imagine anyone
else trying to fill Emma's shoes it's
easy to forget that China once had a
small role in Hannah Montana after all
she's been cast in so many productions
that is hard to keep up with her back in
the early 2000s Hannah Montana was one
of Disney Channel's most popular sitcoms
and tons of up-and-coming stars snagged
minor roles that would help them further
their careers so we all owe Miley a huge
thank-you and that's a wrap on the 10
stars you forgot we're on Hannah Montana
before you go tell us what your favorite
Disney Channel show is in the comments
below one of our favorites is Andy Mack
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and be sure to give this video
a big thumbs up we'll see you next time
on the things